-I'm so happy you're here.
-Thanks for having me, man.
-I'm a fan of yours.
It's so nice to meet you here.
And I was very excited to meet
your mother, as well, backstage.
-My mom is here. Hi, Mom.
-Where is mom?
Is mom in the audience?
-Where is mother?
-There's ma. Hey, mom!
-Oh, don't pretend like
you're not here.
Hi, Mom. -I know.
It's like,
"Don't put me on camera.
Don't put me on camera."
-She's like, "Don't do it.
That's your job, not mine."
-Mom, you got to be very proud,
very proud of your --
Does your mom get to -- Does she
get to see you perform a lot?
-She's actually -- She came for
the first time last --
this past season?
Yeah. So that was the first time
she saw me employed as an actor,
which is cool, 'cause I'm like,
"Mom, I have a job.
-Mom, things are going pretty
well for this guy, yeah.
I've got to say,
the new season just came out,
and it is the
number-1 show on Netflix.
I mean, is that after --
Immediately after
the release on Thursday.
Congrats on that.
In fact, a lot of fans have
already finished
the whole third season,
if that's even possible.
-How?
-Wait.
Someone is waving her hand.
You finished it all?
-You finished it?
-How? When?
-Are you okay?
[ Laughter ]
-No, I mean,
where did you find the --
-I started it Friday night
and finished it Saturday night.
-So you marathoned?
That's a lot of hours.
And what -- Unbiased,
what is your review of the show?
Clearly, you liked it.
-It's the best season.
-Whoa! It's the best season.
That's what you want.
-I will Venmo you later.
-That's not paid advertisement.
-I'll get her Venmo.
-Oh, yeah, you'll get her --
Yeah, her Venmo, yeah.
Besides these great fans
that you have for the show --
'Cause, man,
you got a giant fan base.
They really support you.
How about celebrity fans?
Anyone ever shock you
where you're like,
"Oh, my gosh,
they watch the show?"
-Yeah, yeah.
We've had some interesting ones.
I think the funniest one --
I grew up in Orlando,
so I'm a huge Orlando Magic fan.
-Yeah.
-And I got to FaceTime with
Shaquille O'Neal.
And so, you know, I got the,
"Hey, man, hey, how are you?"
-Whoa. Wow. That's a --
-"Congratulations on
the show, man.
Congratulations.
We really like --"
-"What's happening
with this new season?"
-"Can you spoil anything?"
"Sorry, Shaq. Can't do that."
-I love everyone's
FaceTiming each other.
No one does that with me.
It's very funny.
-I'll FaceTime you.
-Yeah. You will?
-Yeah.
-You're a very funny
human being.
We were talking backstage,
and I was saying,
"What's it like shooting this
in the jungle?"
And very interesting stories of
shooting in the jungle
that I didn't even think about.
But can you just run through
maybe two or three?
-Sure. Yeah. Yeah.
So, this show,
it takes a lot of effort,
physical effort, exertion.
So, we shot in Barbados
this year.
And we were in the jungle for
an extended period of time.
And there was one day in
particular where the universe
just decided to not work
in my favor.
-But -- Why not, though?
I think it's good.
-Sure, yeah, no.
-People need to know this.
-So, there's a stunt
that happens
at the end of the final episode.
Spoiler alert.
-Yeah. I looked right at you.
Don't spoil. Yeah.
-I'm not going to do it.
Don't do it.
But, anyways, that happens.
And it was
a very exhausting stunt.
So I'm leaning against a tree,
and next thing you know,
my arm is on fire.
And I'm like,
"What is going on?"
So, one of our Bajan crew
members looked at me and says,
"That's poison tree sap,
and that's all over your arm."
So I'm like,
"Oh, that's awesome."
-Poison tree sap?
-Yeah.
So, they put me in a van
and they started
putting ointments on me
that I have no idea what it is,
but I'm just kind of
going with the flow.
So, I recover from that,
and I'm talking to my director
sort of like, "I think I'm okay.
I have a pulse. I'm not dying."
And I feel something hit me
in the back of the head.
And he's looking at me like --
-This is a real story.
-This is 100% true.
-Like a smack.
-It was a full-on, like...
Jerked my body forward.
And I was like, "What --"
-"What was that?"
-And he goes, "Bird.
That was a bird.
A bird just -- A bird flew into
the back of your head."
-See, that made me laugh
there 'cause --
So, a bird attacks you
after the poison tree sap.
Yeah. And then a bird
dive-bombs your head.
-Yep.
-And you go, "Oh, my God.
Well, that's it. Go home."
-I'm just trying to make
a TV show.
-Hey, man, just trying to
entertain people.
-Yeah.
-And then you go,
"Well, let's do another take.
I'm good.
Let's just enjoy
being in the jungle."
-Yeah, the jungle.
It's just so great.
It's a lovely place.
Highly recommend it.
-Yeah. And you're there.
You're in nature.
It's beautiful.
-So beautiful.
So humid. So, so humid.
-It starts to rain.
-And, so, it starts to rain,
says one of our crew members.
He looks at me and he goes,
"Oh, thank God.
It's raining finally.
This will cool us down."
So, I'm like,
"Oh, wow. It's raining."
And I look up, and, immediately,
he says, "Nope, not rain.
That's monkeys peeing."
And a monkey --
a monkey literally pees
directly in my eyeball.
A monkey peed in my eyeball.
So, um...
-That's a great day at work.
-Yeah, so,
I got poison tree sap,
a bird flew into
the back of my head,
and a monkey pissed
on my eyeball, so...
-And you still look like this.
I mean, look at this guy.
Come on. It's a nip slip!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's a -- Yeah.
-Yeah, you missed --
-Yeah, we should blur that out.
-Yeah, you missed
one of the buttons.
-Yeah, oopsie-poopsie.
-Missed one of
the buttons on there, yeah.
-I think it's lopsided, too.
I think I got to --
-Yeah, you missed a few buttons
when you put the shirt on.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Chase Stokes in
"Outer Banks."
Take a look at this.
-That's exactly what my dad
would do to call me home.
Sarah, that -- that pattern,
those bells.
[ Bells ringing ]
The ding...ding...ding-ding.
Sarah, that --
that's him calling me home.
-I know -- It -- Yeah.
It -- That's --
It's really weird.
But it's not him.
-Okay, how do --
how do you know that?
-You know why.
-No.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
-I'm sorry.
-No, no, listen.
Maybe -- maybe
you get beaten enough,
you aren't able to see the
miracle right in front of you.
I mean, that's exactly how he
used to call me home.
Maybe it is him.
Maybe the universe
is trying to give me a gift,
and we're not even --
-Okay.
-What?
-Okay. I get it.
You want to go to the tower
to go look?
Go look, okay?
-Yeah.
Chase Stokes, everybody.
Season 3 of "Outer Banks"
is streaming now on Netflix.
We'll be right back with
Micky Dolenz.
Stick around, everybody.